You know, like I said before, you know, I actually saw your video...
...even before I had the chance to have this interview opportunity and,...
...you know, it's really interesting to see the mix of hip-hop and then,...
...some kind of mixing classical and jazz violin... going on and...
...I just wanted to first get into your writing background history.
...and you are... a guy from Los Angeles.
And... are you still pretty much exposed to hip-hop music?
Yeah! Well, a whole bunch of different styles of music are there, I mean.
You know, I grew up on hip-hop, jazz also, classical, you know, classic rock.
I love all kinds of music so I definitely think that, you know.
And I was lucky enough to grow up in L.A.,...
...where there's just a whole bunch of different cultures that are all mixed up in the city.
So, you know, I'm very lucky to come from a very diverse city.
Did you actually get exposed into some Japanese music as well?
Just the children's songs that my parents taught me...
...but I don't know too many of the artists here.
Not one of those pop songs?
Not too many. I know a couple...
...like the songs you hear in the anime shows 'cause I'm a big fan of Bleach.
Okay.
So, the songs from Bleach, I know.
I heard you started playing violin when you were four.
Yeah.
And you pretty much went on continuing until now, you never sort of... quit it.
Why, I did for a little bit.
When I went to college,...
...my first day of university at USC, I said,...
..."I don't wanna play violin anymore. I wanna do something else."
So, I quit my major and I went to jazz school instead.
And so, for that first year, I didn't really play violin too much.
I did mostly vocal jazz training and stuff like that.
And then after that, I realized well, jazz is great and I'm really having a good time...
...but I'm wasting all this education that I've built up over the years with the violin.
So, I should maybe try to combine the two or, you know, bring it back on my terms.